today I want to talk to you about the
one subject we also love back in school
growing up and that is math I'm Patrick
David and today I want to talk to you
about why I believe a life is all about
math now I'm not talking about the math
that most people think about I'm not
talking about the Pythagorean theorem
where it's a square plus B Square equals
C squared or you know Einsteins e equals
MC square or PI you know 3.14159 I
remember those days of pie or cpctc do
you remember cpctc do you remember
geometry you got to prove all these
theorems you know congruent parts of
congruent triangles like who cares if
they're congruent right I think the only
time we ever use geometry is when you
play pool if you do play pool but
anyways don't get over one for a second
here before I make my point you hear me
out first then see if this makes sense
to you or not I believe life is all
about nothing I'll tell you why
literally every single thing in life can
be linked to math and the reason why I
love this is because the great thing
about math is math formulas can be
proven see there are many formulas in
math that you got in algebra math
analysis whatever it was everything can
be proven and I will tell you a life is
about the same way as well so people say
well give me a bright path what do you
mean real life is all about math you're
telling me health is all about math of
course everything about health is about
math how is health linked to Matt well
if I don't exercise if I don't have a
good diet if I don't get enough sleep if
I don't eat the right things there is a
higher chance of me not being healthy
and if I exercise I do the complete
opposite there's a higher chance of me
being healthy because health is all
about math if you think about even
health you may say well how about heart
attacks or how about aneurysms how about
all these other sub diabetes
some of it is math based on parents some
of it is math based on a lot of
different things but there's a math
formula to it career that's all about
math if you get a college degree you
have a higher you know percentage of
getting a good job if you're you know
hard-working companies are going to keep
you if you're all about working on
yourself you have a higher chance of
keeping it
it's all about math marriage some people
say well Patrick that's a little touchy
subject thus a marriage is also all
about math it's all about math if you
don't work on your marriage and you no
longer do date nights there's a higher
likelihood that marriage is not going to
work out if you don't tell your wife
your lover or you your husband you love
them there's a high likelihood there's
going to be problems eventually because
it's a math formula if you think about
parenting raising kids in a bad
community higher percentage of dempsey
and drugs and many other things this
doesn't mean they won't seat in a good
community they're still going to see it
if they go to a private school because
you know how the stories go but it's a
percentage because it's about math in
parenting if you tell your kids you'll
love them
you've heard that exercise I've talked
about it a couple episodes ago about
geniuses and kids how kids are being
told by parents how great they are and
kids who are raised by parents being
told how terrible they are the
percentages of how those kids turned out
because it's about math finances I don't
even tell you that that's all math love
and dating it's all about math you may
say give me a break love and dating well
listen when you go on a date with a guy
or a girl the first time and you go
through your questions right what
happens when you go through your
questions you're doing the formula in
your brain and you say you know the last
relationship he dated wasn't that good
and it ended pretty bad and his last
three of them all ended back why is that
is there something wrong with them is
there something wrong with her what
about this what about his parents he's
not close with his mom he's not close
all this stuff is math that you do in
your own mind is what you do and don't
tell me you and I haven't done it before
my wife did it with me knowing this was
a risk she took right happiness is all
about math if you're unhappy people
there's a higher likelihood of you being
happy it's a basic formula if you run
negative people who constantly complain
there's a very high likelihood of you
being negative and you'll be miserable
with life because it's a mathematical
formula faith some of the biggest
Christians are mathematicians some of
the biggest spiritual people are all
about math because they figured it out
based on a mathematical formula both
sides by the way sports without math
doesn't even belong to me no one would
even watch sports if there wasn't a
leaders bulletin if there was
scoreboard people wouldn't be watching
sports it's all about math the only
reason we like sports because somebody
wins and somebody loses politics do I
even need to tell you how much of
politics is about math when they do the
calculations of what color tie to wear
blue or red do I wear jeans to relate to
middle America because I'm talking to
middle America this is all politics CNN
Fox MSNBC all math is what it's about
business entrepreneurship is all about
math the list goes on I can list
everything it's all about math now
instead of letting this overwhelm you
you just got to know no matter what it
is any of this stuff that when we get
married I've been having conversations
about this what if it doesn't work out
what if it doesn't work out do you
really know if it's going to work out no
so there is some risk we all got to take
there is risk with marriage there is
risk with having kids nowadays do you
realize all these sexting and Facebook
and social media and pornography online
men there's a risk with parenting and
raising kids there's a risk with
finances there's a risk with hell
there's a risk with curry or happiness
everything there's a risk but there are
some risks that you're willing to take
and just don't put the pressure on
yourself
for having to 100% make it work because
the risk is always going to be there all
you need to do is look for the math and
any different aspects of your life and
in my opinion it will make and take more
pressure off of you if you look at it in
this way you don't have to agree with it
love to hear your thoughts about it but
that's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel